This episode is brought to you by even
cero watches.
What's up guys?
Jared here,
if you've been following South Park and
our South Park podcast perspect our
authortalk,
you've probably noticed that the show
feels a little different these days.
Last season South Park often explored
our reactions,
the current events,
especially outrage and despair.
And while that's still front and center,
this season hones in on a different
feeling resignation.
So far south park has been showing how
the modern world has overwhelmed,
devastated and just exhausted us.
So let's get super depressed about the
world in this wise crack.
Quick take on the first four episodes of
South Park season 22 and is always
spoilers ahead.
But first a quick recap of the season.
So far in episode one,
Sharon freaks out about the daily school
shootings at South Park elementary
chosen were shot.
They were killed at a school where they
were supposed to be
[inaudible].
No one else seems to care.
Uh Huh.
What else is going on?
Meanwhile,
Cartman is Jessica Jonesing to
investigate these seemingly impossible
claim.
That token hasn't seen Black Panther in
episode two.
Father Maxi.
Now the butts of a plethora of pedophile
jokes leaves his post in a crisis of
faith only to find hope with butters.
Now of course,
a priest being best friends with the kid
is a bad look and the archdiocese
mistakenly sends out a cleanup crew to
take care of the issue.
Episode Three C's,
south parks,
resident Christmas mass,
Scott lose his position after a series
of ambient fueled tweets.
While episode four takes the Marsh
family from South Park to a Colorado
weed farm or randy goes toe to toe with
big vape.
So what do all these episodes have?
Income?
A few things,
but we're going to start with maybe the
biggest sensitization.
Don't understand South Park's commentary
on desensitization.
We have to understand the way the media
contributes to an alters collective
grief scholars,
Arthur and joan climb and describe the
way in which images of suffering are
appropriated to appeal emotionally and
morally to certain audiences and how
these images have become extremely
important to the media.
The problem,
however,
is that aside from just reporting on
tragic events,
the media commercializes victims who are
taken up into processes of global
marketing and business competition,
when experiences turned into commodities
that are leveraged by mainstream or
social media to give us all the fields,
something strange happens.
The result is that in the end we become
numb to the suffering of others.
South Park is telling us something.
We already know that it's easy to be
impassioned about a thing at first,
but it's equally easy to burn out.
In episode one,
we see southpark beset with a plague of
school shootings during which most
behave with a colt nonchalance.
Well,
I got this one.
Nobody seems to give a shit except
Sharon
series.
Did you not hear what your child said?
Kids died at his school
instead of listening to her,
please to think of the children,
Randy and the rest of south park believe
the real issue is that she's on her
period or worse entering menopause.
You see Mr.
Marsh,
menopause is almost like a super period
and it's been known to last for up to
two years.
Oh by God and from their episodes three
and four open with gunshots at South
Park elementary before panning over to
tell the more pressing story.
Desensitization is so rampant.
The citizens of south park aren't even
outraged about Catholic priests
molesting children.
They've simply resigned to making jokes
about it.
The great one,
Nelson Salvation in a little boy's
mouth.
I'm going to post that one for sure.
Even when his son is theoretically in
danger.
Randy can help but crack jokes and post
them on social media,
but where would prisco this late at
night to a midnight sale at boys Rs.
What'd she say?
She sat too.
I midnight sale at buys our eyes.
Got It.
Can I pose that?
We see here how social media makes it
that much easier to become desensitized
by berating us with images and ideas of
suffering.
Even providing an incentive to think of
these things as jokes or potential posts
rather than serious events.
In all these cases,
no one even tries to make the world any
better.
They're too busy just trying to bear the
nightmare world they're living in.
So how can these horrible things be
fixed?
If everyone has become indifferent,
to be blunt,
they can't.
The people just become exhausted and
eventually submit.
No matter how much sense Sharon makes
the townspeople write her off and
eventually she becomes comfortably numb,
barely reacting.
When her son stand becomes the latest
victim in a school shooting.
It's not the end of the world.
Maxis quest to become a better priest
ends the same way.
He rejects the churches institutional
coverup of the kid touching epidemic and
slaughters the clean up crew with their
own home boney,
but he's also accepted that he can't
save the church,
nor can he expect the adults to change
their behavior.
All he can do his vow to do the right
thing.
As an individual,
it looks like there's not much choice
but to go with the flow and accept the
world as given as horrible as it is,
which is a lesson kyle learns the hard
way,
courtesy of his good friend Mr Hankey,
when everyone's favorite Christmas poo
finds himself in trouble for taking
ambien and tweeting things like
the city council members are a bunch of
pussy licking is llamas.
Mr Hankey not only refuses to admit he
did anything wrong,
he continues to act like an asshole.
Mr Hankey looks for help clearing his
name,
but no one will help him because as
Gerald says,
I learned a long time ago that if you
defend poop,
you get stained.
Finally,
Mr Hankey finds hope in Kyle who vows to
stick by his friend.
Meanwhile,
strong woman gives birth to a quintuplet
of PC babies who react negatively to any
violations of political correctness.
X gives me,
sorry I until food aisle.
The babies and the Hanky collide when
the Christmas Poo puts on an early
Christmas celebration and the baby's cry
at even the most benign of holiday.
Well wishes Mr Hankey goes off the rails
and Kyle's attempts to calm the
situation.
Leaves him stained both literally and
metaphorically.
Yeah,
like in the end,
Heil has to give up and stop defending
his friend because if he doesn't,
he'll get ostracized to they're gone.
You went then to erase me too.
It turns out Cartherin was right.
I want to stand by my friend.
Let's see how that goes for you in 28
so what happens when you want to fight
back against an exhausting,
infuriating world when you want to just
make things better or steep?
The pressures of modern life aside from
the gunshots in the intro episode four
starts very differently than the others.
Instead of being desensitized,
we see randy finally get riled up after
three episodes of handwaving the crises
around him.
What possibly moves randy,
just take action.
A picture of a dog's butthole.
Seriously.
Dog's butt hole.
That's what we're doing now.
Huh?
From there,
he decides to abandoned South Park and
move on up to Colorado bar where he can
live a life of tegrity there he starts
growing weed but refuses to participate
in the progress promised by executives
at big vape there by pitting his tegrity
against their concepts of progress.
Your Mommy teach you.
It doesn't pay to mess with progress.
Yeah,
she taught Ms.
Dot.
Mouse too.
If you're going to fight for your
tegrity,
don't forget to bring it down.
Of course,
this is funny because randy really has
no tegrity to speak of.
His home spun style doesn't come from
growing up on a farm or being born into
the life.
It's just a random choice.
A guy in a small town made his accent is
a clear expectation that he picks up and
drops on a whim.
Yeah,
whatever all you're doing is blowing
smoke.
Sorry,
Freudian
deep.
What happened to your accent?
He even uses the language of Tegrity as
an advertising device at the end of the
episode made with a little color out of
integrity.
In the end,
his tegrity nonsense is made of the same
stuff as the claims to progress that
carbon and the vape executive make.
You can be a part of progress or you can
get run over by it.
Just as tegrity is a costume randy puts
on to sell the jungle Kush progress is
just an advertising device.
It's an excuse to move a product with
flavors that target children
relax,
trust,
and can we based on price
and south park even the attempts to heal
such an exhausting world,
whether through progress or integrity
are totally self and foolish,
but what does tegrity even mean while
the hero's try to hash it out.
Check out our southpark podcast,
respect our authority links in the
description
and as you guys may have noticed,
I've dialed it up a little bit today
with this little bad boy of in Shero
Watch.
It's actually been years since I've
owned a watch,
but I got to tell you now that I've got
this finch Arrow,
I'm digging it,
especially since I'm trying to stop
being glued to my freaking phone.
Becerra watches have a distinct looking
quality field that will take your look
up a level if you're bored with Cookie
Cutter Department Store watches,
you'll like.
Vincero is bold and daring designs and
the quality is top notch in Sheros
philosophy is to focus on impeccable
craftsmanship.
Their product isn't about a bunch of
fancy specs are slick marketing.
It's all about creating watches with
meticulous attention to detail.
And a commitment to quality.
And the best part is you don't even have
to be rolling in dough to get one like
this.
All this elegance is available to you at
an accessible price,
but don't take it for me.
Let the numbers speak for themselves.
And Cheryl just received their 12,005
star review.
So had given Cheryl watches.com/wise
crack and use the Promo code wise crack
to get 15% off your first order.
When it comes to dressing for success,
I'll take a shot with the company whose
name literally translates to,
I will win.
So check them out for yourself.
Click here or the link in the
description and use the promo code wise
crackers for 15% off your first order.
And as always,
thanks for watching guys.
Peace.